vamos a las noticias económicas con
Daniela Blandón actualizamos Daniela y
comenzamos con silicon Valley Bank
nuevamente y los elementos Son nuevos se
conocen más razones de su colapso y
Ángela muy buenos días de nuevo pues la
prensa de Estados Unidos concretamente
el periódico de Wall Street journal
habla de que ya hay una investigación en
curso por parte del departamento de
Justicia que podría apuntar directamente
al expresidente del silicon Valley Bank
quien es Greg Baker y también su ex jefe
financiero denial Beck ambos relevados
en medio de la intervención que hizo el
Gobierno supuestamente ellos habrían
vendido acciones de la compañía apenas
una semana antes de que colapsara y esto
quiere decir que posiblemente o que muy
seguramente sabían de que iba sabían que
iba a quebrar también se conoció que el
otro banco quebrado que es el signature
Bank y tres de sus exaltos ejecutivos
Fueron demandados por accionistas que
acusaron a esta entidad de proclamar de
manera fra que era financieramente
sólida esto apenas tres días antes de
que fuera tomada por el estado entre
tanto pues son las pequeñas empresas los
principales clientes de estas firmas en
quiebra quienes están luchando por
cubrirse en medio de este angustioso
cierre bancario escuchemos uno de los
testimonios
Tan pronto como nos enteramos del hecho
recibimos un correo electrónico de la
compañía que maneja nuestra nómina
diciendo que nuestro depósito no se
procesaría porque esta firma ejecuta sus
depósitos a través de silicon Valley
Bank lo cual fue inesperado para mí
entonces fue como decirle a mis
empleados escucha la nómina No se va a
pagar
como pequeña empresa una de las
principales cosas que quieres hacer es
pagar a todos tus empleados a tiempo
afortunadamente parece que eso se
resolverá a partir de este caso como se
están comportando los mercados bueno
Wall Street acaba de abrir abrió mixto
pero con fuertes variaciones por ejemplo
los dos principales índices o dos de sus
los principales índices que son el dow
Jones de industriales y el nasdaq
Tecnológico pierden entre el uno y el 2%
en las primeras operaciones del mercado
y el estándar está subiendo más del uno
coma seis por ciento Mientras tanto si
nos vamos para Europa las bolsas van en
caída libre a pesar de que los
reguladores y los ejecutivos de
financieros de todo el mundo pues han
tratado de mitigar todas estas
preocupaciones de contagio del colapso
del silicon Valley Punk las acciones del
gigante Credit suiz se desploman en más
del 20% un nuevo mínimo histórico las
bolsas asiáticas tuvieron ganancias
después de un martes de drásticas caídas
los ojos hoy están puestos en la reunión
del Banco Central europeo que parece
inclinarse por seguir subiendo sus tasas
de interés y de la que daremos detalles
en nuestra Crónica de mañana y la que me
prometió hace un rato Reino Unido ya
presentó sus previsiones económicas para
este año y señora lo primero que hizo el
ministro de finanzas Jeremy Hunt al
presentar esos planes para el futuro
próximo
dar cierto parte de tranquilidad sobre
la economía es un parte agridulce diría
yo porque dijo que las previsiones
apuntan a que este año sí va a haber una
ligera contracción del 0,2% en el
producto interno bruto sin embargo sí se
va a poder esquivar la recesión técnica
según estas previsiones que ocurre
cuando hay dos trimestres consecutivos
de caída en el producto interno bruto
también descartó que vaya a haber una
ola de gastos importantes o de grandes
recortes de impuestos Aunque sí confirmó
que se va a extender por tres meses esta
programa de subsidios a las facturas de
energía para los hogares entre sus
promesas para este año están llevar la
inflación anual del 10% al 3% para
finales de 2023 una meta bastante
difícil de cumplir y también quiere
reducir sustancialmente la deuda pública
no solamente este año sino también en
los próximos cinco años como dato de
cierre de este tema le cuento que Gran
Bretaña es la única Economía del grupo
de los siete que aún no ha recupera do
su tamaño anterior a la pandemia
Y eso lo hemos hablado varias veces en
esta Crónica de economía Microsoft y
Google Daniela compiten cabeza por la
Inteligencia artificial Así es la de
estar dada openi de Microsoft aseguró
que ya lanzó su poderoso modelo de
Inteligencia artificial conocido como
gpt 4 que es una actualización de la
versión del 3.5 de esta manera Está
allanando más el escenario para la
proliferación de esta tecnología que
trata de simular el cerebro humano esta
startup dijo que el servicio será para
suscriptores del chat en chipity Plus y
para desarrolladores de software y para
dar muestra de lo que puede llegar a ser
reveló que fue ensayada con un examen
para graduarse de una facultad de
derecho de Estados Unidos y este robot
Tuvo una calificación 10% más alta que
los estudiantes humanos la versión
anterior había tenido una nota del 10%
inferior así que están tratando como
demostrar que Está avanzando esta
tecnología en medio de esta puja no
coincidencia que también alphabet que es
la matriz de Google anunciara que allá
tiene lista lo que llamó una varita
mágica para su software de Inteligencia
artificial que puede redactar
prácticamente cualquier documento en
tiempo récord en los próximos días se
espera que su competidor Microsoft
también haga lo mismo presente su
procesador de textos y tenemos tiempo
para nuestra cifra del día 100 millones
de dólares Esta es la parte cien mil
millones de dólares es la participación
que ha venido adquiriendo el fondo de
Abu dabi y 42 invite Dance que es la
matriz de tiktok la agencia
especializada bloomberg aseguró que esto
querría decir que la empresa está
valorada en unos 220 mil millones de
dólares el precio cambiante de la
compañía refleja Ese temor que se ha
expandido sobre que pueda hacer una
amenaza para la seguridad bloomberg
asegura que inclusive tiktok estaría
pensando en separarse de su matriz para
disipar esas dudas Aunque lo ven como
una opción que todavía no está en la
mesa Daniela gracias a ustedes y nos
vemos mañana con más noticias Así es nos
vemos mañana